نتابع كل هذه التطورات بتحليل مع ضيفنا من
بيروت الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
العميد الياس حنا اهلا بك عميد الياس تطور
المعارك في الجبهتين الجنوبيه والشرقيه
كيف تقراه
مريم لا شيء جديد على هذه الساحه لا نزال
كما كنا منذ يومين او ثلاثه وحتى اسبوع
منذ بدء هذا الهجوم الشيء البارز هو فقط
في الجبهه الشرقيه في محمود لماذا بخموت
لانه بعد الانسحاب الجيش الاوكراني
واستلامها من قبل الجيش العادي وليس من
فاجنر اصبحت هذه المنطقه بدرجه عاليه من
الهشاشه وهو المكان الوحيد الذي يمكن
لاوكرانيا او الجيش الاوكراني ان يحقق
تقدم عبر التطويق لماذا لانه ليس لديها
عمق محصن كما في الجنوب كما في زبروت كما
في اوريكيف ميليتوبول وغيرها هنا بيت
القصيد اذا حقق الجيش الاوكراني شيء في
هذه المنطقه تكون ضربه معنويه لكل الجيش
الروسي بعد ان خرجت
فاجنر من المعادله هل يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
فعلا عميد الياس حنا بالنظر الى ان الايام
مضت منذ خروج قوات فاجنر من هذه المنطقه
ولم يحدث ذلك التقدم الذي يسعى اليها
الجيش الاوكراني في بخموت
هناك تقدم في الشمال الغربي والجنوب
الغربي وهذا امر صعب جدا مريم عندما نتحدث
عن حرب خنادق وحرب غابات وحرب تقريبا حرب
عصابات وضمن مدن في مكان ما هذا امر صعب
جدا وهذا ما قاله رئيس الاركان الاوكراني
ان الحرب بطيئه لانها مكلفه يعني اليوم
عندما التقدم صعب جدا في هكذا اماكن قائد
الجيش الاوكراني تحدث عن ذلك التباطؤ في
الهجوم المضاد بسبب نقص الذخيره والاسلحه
ودعا الغرب الى تزويد اوكرانيا بالمزيد من
الاسلحه هل هذا ما يدعو او يدفع الجانب
الامريكي على وجه التحديد التفكير ربما
وفق ما نقل بتزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل
العنقوديه
القنابل العنقوديه لديها شيء وحتى السلاح
الذي يطلق من الهاي مارس الاتامس كما يقال
ومداه 300 كلم الى جانب ستورم شادو ولكن
المشكله الاساسيه مريم هي في الحمايه
الجويه للقوات الاوكرانيه التي تتقدم حيث
تلعب الطوافات الروسيه الدوري الاكبر من
هنا القصف البعيد المدى في العمق
الاوكراني على
سبيل المثال فيها قاعده لوجستيه وفيها ما
يقارب العشرين او 25 طائره
وهي طوافات تستعمل لحمايه القوات الروسيه
على جبهه القتال الممتده تقريبا 900 كم ما
الذي تحتكم اليها القوات الاوكرانيه في
هذا المجال في مجال هذه الطائرات للحمايه
كما ذكرت
هناك الحمايه المباشره الحمايه المتنقله
هناك المدافع المضاده لهذه الطائرات بدات
المانيا تزويدها بهذا الامر ولكن هذا
الامر يستلزم وقتا معينا ولكن الافضليه
دائما في القتال الليلي للقوات الاوكرانيه
لان الدبابات والعتاد الجديد هو مجهز
بالقتال الليلي يبدو ان الطوافات ايضا
ليست كما يجب او حتى الدبابات الروسيه
ليست مجهزه بالقتال الليلي العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك